on may 3rd bill and melinda gates
announced separately on twitter they
will be divorcing after 27 years of
marriage
the announcement raises several
questions about the gates's massive
fortune
it's unclear how the couple will divide
their assets or whether they signed a
prenup
but due to the size of their fortune the
split will likely be one of the largest
divorce settlements in history
if bill and melinda do decide to split
the fortune equally
melinda would be worth 65.25 billion
dollars
that would make melinda richer than
mackenzie scott after her divorce from
amazon founder jeff bezos
when the bezos is split in 2019 scott
received about four percent of amazon's
outstanding
shares worth over 35 billion dollars in
that stock is worth far more now with
amazon stock up nearly 75
since then that made her the third
richest woman in the world
and this divorce one of the costliest in
history
and while we can't follow the money on
every high profile divorce
here are some that stack up the divorce
of harold hamm and sue ann arnell was a
years-long saga
in 2015 after three years of bitter
court proceedings
oil tycoon harold tried to end his
26-year marriage with su-ann
by writing her a check for more than 974
million dollars
she deposited it but then changed her
mind decided she wanted more
and filed an appeal seeking a bigger
share of the then 13.7 billion dollar
fortune
tied to ham's 75 ownership in publicly
traded continental resources
in april 2015 the oklahoma supreme court
ended the saga
granting harold's motion to dismiss her
appeal reasoning that su-ann had agreed
to the settlement by
signing and depositing the check
afterwards
su-ann funded a political action
committee that succeeded in its effort
to
unseat the judge who presided over the
divorce the divorce of steve and elaine
nguyen was another 850 million dollar
doozy
the co-founders of the casino giant wynn
resorts divorced for the second time in
2010.
that settlement got elaine a win resorts
board member from 2002
to 2015 11 million shares
then worth an estimated 795 million
dollars
she also received some shares from steve
now
worth 2.3 billion dollars elaine is win
resort's
largest individual shareholder